does a business need to have social aims
that's a question that came in from
twitter reader emma
great question and to answer that
if we step back if we look at a bigger
picture if we look at your business from
a 50 000 foot level if we get into the
philosophy of entrepreneurship
then every business
has a social aim because if you're not
helping people with your company then
you're not going to make money
money comes from helping people you help
somebody solve a problem you're going to
have success in your company
so every business needs to have that
kind of social aim if you're in it just
to make money it's never going to happen
for you
now diving deep back into the question
i believe that every entrepreneur has an
obligation a duty the the right to go
out and contribute to their community
beyond what they're doing with their
business
find something that will help nourish
your soul as an entrepreneur and do it
as soon as you can
you don't have to go and invest a lot of
money when you're first starting out you
don't have a lot of money so you don't
have to put it all into some charity
that you believe in you have a duty to
grow your business because the more your
business grows the more of an impact you
can have in your community
but give your time especially at the
beginning do something that makes you
feel good
do something that gives back to your
community forget about the business side
of it it can be great marketing that
people know that you're part of
something that you're helping your
community out they'll want to go with
you
but forget about that
do it because it's the right thing to do
do it because it makes you feel good do
it because it gives you more energy to
go to your work the next day
and know that you're not only helping
your customers but you're helping all
these other people attached to it as
well
find a cause that you believe in that's
tied to your core
i believe in entrepreneurs
so i've helped out organizations like
junior achievement
where they teach young entrepreneurs
high school students how to become
business owners and i was a mentor for a
number of years and now the main cause
i'm involved with with kiva it's micro
loan system where we've helped support
thousands of businesses get started
mostly in africa
to help these businesses get off the
ground help people get out of poverty
through entrepreneurship
help them support their family bring on
a workforce and enrich their communities
that's something i feel good about
and if that helps my business so be it
but i do it because it's the right thing
to do
so i believe
that every business should also have
something where you're contributing back
to your community around a cause that
you believe in again don't do it because
you think it's the right thing to do
don't be strategic in the cause you're
helping out it's got to come from the
heart it's got to be something that
you're passionate about you love this
charity you love what they stand for
and that passion and energy will flow
back into your business and make you a
better entrepreneur and help you build a
better company
i know what that at the start is it's
really hard
you know entrepreneurs are working
80 hours a week 100 hours a week
whatever it is it's crazy it's crazy
hard
if you do just do that you're gonna burn
out
if you don't have anything that
contributes to nourishing your soul and
making you better and and helping you
see the impact that you are able to have
then you're gonna burn out with your
business
you're not gonna make it by dedicating a
little bit of time
just a little bit of time i'm not saying
spend 10 hours a week at a charity
dedicate a little bit of time
to your favorite charity to something
that means something to you something
gets you excited something where you can
see the direct impact of your time and
effort
do that allow your team to do that
you'll build a better company have more
impact have more money and you'll be
more excited about what you're doing
every day believe thanks for the great
great question
for those of you watching you like the
video please give it that thumbs up
below it makes me want to do more videos
for you and if you have a comment about
this video or question for your business
let me know in the comments below and
i'll make a video reply for you thanks
guys i'll see you soon